This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）为您带来的《艰难历程》（Learn the Hardway）。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都感觉不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个懂行的有牌照的专业人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着一副盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做，听听怎么做。
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
在AHA电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难历程》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生育双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一个骗局。你曾多次篡改这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这动用了大量互联网侦探，才揭露了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士：格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我的天呐。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立抗挫力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难险阻，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约定时，她们决定采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说
that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s, and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world.
相信你的女朋友们。在Iheart radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《女朋友，相信我，宝贝》（Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe）。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），在这个播客中，我们探讨二十岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友、老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个地方。
It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, we're talking about an all too common mental dilemma or barrier that we tend to face a lot in our 20s. And that is chronic indecisiveness, struggling or being unable to make a decision to save our lives, getting stuck in this rut of analysis of information seeking, of hypotheticals and pros and cons lists, and then eventually making a decision, taking action, and finding that we are constantly ruminating and thinking about the alternative and what might have been. It is exhaustive. It is time consuming, it's unproductive, and most of all, it's really mentally frustrating
很高兴你能来到这里，收听又一期节目，当然，我们一直在剖析二十岁时的心理学。今天，我们要讨论的是一个在我们二十多岁时经常面临的太常见的心理困境或障碍。那就是长期的优柔寡断，拼尽全力也难以或无法做出决定，陷入信息搜集、假设以及利弊清单的分析泥潭中，然后最终做出决定，采取行动，却发现自己不断地反刍和思考另一种选择以及本来可能会发生的事情。这让人筋疲力尽。这很耗时，没有成效，最重要的是，这在心理上真的很令人沮丧
to have to overthink every minute little decision or detail of our lives. There are a lot of decisions that we feel compelled to make in our 20s, like what we want to do with our lives, what we want to do for work, what kind of person we want to be, what kind of person we want to date, where we want to go to school, where to live, where to travel to, whether to travel or to save money to take that risk or play it safe. Those are some really hefty choices. Ones that I think every one of us struggles not to overthink because it feels like each decision we make, we always have to give up something else.
对我们生活中的每一分钟、每一个微小的决定或细节都要过度思考。在我们二十多岁的时候，有很多决定是我们觉得不得不做的，比如我们想用生命做什么，想做什么工作，想成为什么样的人，想和什么样的人约会，想去哪里上学，住在哪里，去哪里旅行，是去旅行还是存钱去冒那个险，还是稳妥行事。这些都是非常沉重的选择。我认为我们每个人都在努力不去做过度的思考，因为感觉我们做出的每一个决定，总是意味着我们必须放弃别的东西。
There is this loss of what could have been that we're very afraid of. And so instead of this possibility of having to recognize what we have to, to give up by choosing a certain path, we stay stagnant. We get so caught up in the benefits that we might be missing out on that we never actually move forward. I think this decade is a wonderful decade of opportunity, no doubt about that. Our adult lives are really just beginning. There are so many doors that remain open to us, but it's also a decade where we feel like the stakes are really high because of how formative these years seem to be. We don't want to kind of be too rash, in closing ourselves off or restricting ourselves to any opportunities.
我们非常害怕失去本可能拥有的东西。因此，我们没有去认识到选择某条道路所必须放弃的东西的可能性，而是保持停滞不前。我们过于纠结于可能错过的利益，以至于从未真正向前迈进。我认为这个十年是一个充满机遇的精彩十年，毫无疑问。我们的成年生活才刚刚开始。有那么多扇门对我们敞开，但这也是一个让我们觉得利害攸关的十年，因为这些岁月似乎具有极大的形成意义。我们不想过于轻率地关闭自己或将自己局限于任何机会中。
And in that way, we tend to borrow a lot of stress from the future, and we catastrophize and imagine a life where we are unhappy until it feels like it's destiny. We also tend to waste a lot of time contemplating, and that time that we spend contemplating, we could be spending actually seeing a result and being decisive. So it makes a really kind of toxic cycle. Well, I think that it's time that we talk about it today. I want to get into all the nitty gritty. The psychology, of course, of what makes us so indecisive at times,
通过这种方式，我们往往从未来借来很多压力，把生活灾难化，想象着一种让我们感到不幸的生活，直到它感觉像是命中注定。我们也往往浪费很多时间去沉思，而花在沉思上的时间，本可以用来实际看到结果并保持果断。所以这形成了一个相当恶毒的循环。好吧，我认为今天是时候讨论这个了。我想深入探讨所有细枝末节。当然，还有那些有时让我们如此优柔寡断的心理学，
why we struggle to make not just big decisions, but small decisions, daily decisions, some of us more than others and what that contributes to in the long run, but also how to be active rather than passive in our lives. How do we let go of our indecision and accept all the possibilities for what could happen, all the different options, and still feel confident that we are kind of making the right one? Still feel confident in ourselves and our intuition, even if it feels scary. How do we kind of break out of the procrastination and the contemplation cycle? And as someone who deals with this on a daily, even when it comes to this podcast and
为什么我们不仅在重大决定上，而且在小决定、日常决定上都苦苦挣扎，其中一些人甚至比其他人更严重，从长远来看，这会导致什么，以及如何在生活中变得积极而不是被动。我们如何放下优柔寡断，接受可能发生的一切可能性、所有不同的选项，并且仍然对自己能够做出正确的选择感到自信？即使感到害怕，也依然对自我和直觉充满信心？我们如何打破拖延和沉思的循环？作为一个每天都要面对这个问题的人，甚至当涉及到这个播客和
questioning, you know, what topics to do, what to write about, what studies to quote, what decisions I need to be making. Trust me, we are in the same boat. I have a lot to say about this, so let's get into it. Okay, so firstly, what is the actual problem with being indecisive? Why are we even talking about it? Well, I think there are obviously a few problems with chronic indecisiveness. Firstly, you never really gain a sense of agency or mastery over your life, your choices and your experiences, you leave them up to chance because you never feel ready to make a decision. Secondly, I think chronic indecisiveness allows us to be ruled by fear, and that fear means that we aren't always actually going to make the best choices. We're just going to make the easiest
质疑，你知道，做什么主题，写什么内容，引用什么研究，我需要做出什么决定。相信我，我们都在同一条船上。我有很多话要说，让我们切入正题吧。好的，首先，优柔寡断的真正问题是什么？我们为什么还要讨论它？嗯，我认为长期的优柔寡断显然有几个问题。首先，你永远无法真正获得对生活、选择和经历的自主权或掌控权，你把它们交给了运气，因为你从未觉得自己准备好做出决定。其次，我认为长期的优柔寡断让我们受制于恐惧，而这种恐惧意味着我们并不总是能做出最好的选择。我们只会做出最简单的选择
one, the one that leaves us feeling safest. And I think indecisiveness also is, is a huge time racter, right? I think we become very conscious of all the things that we could be doing in the time that it takes for us to make a decision. Now, I often encounter this misconception that people who are indecisive are lazy, but I actually think that that is the furthest thing from the truth. When you are someone who struggles deciding between things, making decisions, making choices, actually what you're getting caught up in is the constant mental equations that you're
那个让我们感到最安全的决定。而且我认为优柔寡断也是一个巨大的时间杀手，对吧？我认为我们变得非常清楚，在我们做决定所需的时间里，我们本可以做所有这些事情。现在，我经常遇到这种误解，认为优柔寡断的人很懒，但我实际上认为这与事实相去甚远。当你是一个在事情之间难以抉择、难以做决定、难以进行选择的人时，你实际上陷入的是你一直在做的持续的心理方程式中
you're doing where you're considering every possible outcome, every possible scenario. I think a lot of the time our indecisiveness comes down to this like very unconscious fear of choosing wrong, a fear of making a mistake, of not being perfect, of disappointing others or disappointing ourselves. Now, this is something that psychologists do have a way of measuring. one of the most common questionnaires is the frost indecisiveness scale. And this essentially asks participants to rate a series of statements between strongly disagree and strongly agree. And they include like things such as like I try to put off making decisions. I have a hard time planning my free time.
你在思考每一个可能的结果，每一个可能的场景。我认为很多时候，我们的优柔寡断归结为一种非常无意识的对选错的恐惧，对犯错的恐惧，对不够完美的恐惧，对让别人失望或让自己失望的恐惧。现在，这是心理学家确实有方法衡量的事情。最常见的问卷之一就是福斯特优柔寡断量表（Frost Indecisiveness Scale）。这基本上是要求参与者在强烈反对和强烈同意之间对一系列陈述进行评分。其中包括诸如我尽量推迟做决定。我很难规划我的空闲时间之类的东西。
I often worry about making the wrong choice. And it seems that deciding on the most trivial things takes me a lot of time. These questions really get to the bottom of not just how indecisive we are, but why we are indecisive. Here's the scary thing. The higher that someone scores on this scale, the lower that they tend to score on measures of life satisfaction. Now, this is based on a study conducted in the Netherlands a few years back, whereby they
我经常担心做出错误的选择。而且似乎决定最琐碎的事情也要花掉我很多时间。这些问题不仅触及了我们有多优柔寡断的核心，还触及了我们为什么优柔寡断。可怕的是：一个人在这个量表上的得分越高，他们在生活满意度指标上的得分往往就越低。现在，这是基于几年前在荷兰进行的一项研究，通过该研究，他们
wanted to see if there was any correlation between indecisiveness and our overall. well-being. And there definitely were some. People who were self-reporting that they put off decisions, that they were worried about making the wrong choice. They were also the same kinds of people who were more likely to say, if I could do my life over again, I would do it. The conditions of my life are not great. There are a lot of things that I want to change, but I don't feel able to, which I think just shows the link between not feeling a sense of control over your life that actually contributes to you being indecisive because you don't feel like anything you do is going to make much of a difference.
想要看看优柔寡断与我们的整体幸福感之间是否存在任何相关性。答案是绝对有的。那些自陈会推迟做决定、担心选错的人。他们也往往是那些更倾向于说“如果能重来一次，我会这么做”、“我的生活状况不太好，有很多我想改变的事情，但我觉得自己无能为力”的人，我认为这恰恰说明了缺乏对生活的控制感实际上会导致你的优柔寡断，因为你觉得你做的任何事都不会带来多大改变。
It comes down to something else as well. We are faced with hundreds, if not thousands of decisions every day. We have to think about what time to wake up in the morning, what we want to have for breakfast. We have to think about whether, you know, how are we going to get to? to work, what we're going to listen to on our commute, whether we should call our friend or not, whether we should reply to that text, when we should reply to that text, what to have for lunch, what we're going to wear. The list is honestly endless. And some estimates suggest that in a single
这也归结为别的事情。我们每天都要面对成百上千个决定。我们得考虑早上几点起床，早餐想吃什么。我们得考虑是否，你知道，我们要怎么去上班，通勤路上要听什么，我们是否该给朋友打电话，是否该回那条短信，什么时候回那条短信，午饭吃什么，我们要穿什么。这个清单老实说没完没了。一些估计表明，在单日里
day, you and I are making around 35,000 decisions. That honestly sounds ludicrous. That sounds so excessive. But when you break down just how much we have to decide on in our daily life, that makes a lot of sense. That is a lot of information to process and a lot of decision making for one small brain. And what it can lead to is decision fatigue, whereby the more decisions we feel we need to make and the more important those decisions feel, the lower our quality of decision making is. That occurs for quite obvious reasons, right? When we have a million things to think about, eventually we have to start to cut some corners or we begin to behave impulsively because we don't quite have the necessary cognitive space to rationally and logically think everything through.
你和我大约要做三万五千个决定。这听起来老实说太荒谬了。这听起来太夸张了。但当你细究我们在日常生活中必须做出决定的大小时，这就很有道理了。对于一个小脑瓜来说，这是需要处理的大量信息和大量的决策。而这可能导致决策疲劳，即我们觉得需要做出的决定越多，那些决定感觉越重要，我们的决策质量就越低。这发生的原因相当明显，对吧？当我们有一百万件事情要考虑时，最终我们不得不开始走捷径，或者我们开始表现得很冲动，因为我们没有足够的认知空间来理性、逻辑地把所有事情想清楚。
Or the other alternative is that we just don't make the decision at all. You know, think about when you come home from a long day at work. You're exhausted, you're tired, you're sitting on the couch and you have to decide whether you want to go for a run, whether you want to see your friend, clean your room, or, I don't know, go out for dinner. But suddenly like two hours pass and you realized you've spent that whole time on your phone sitting on the couch. And so you end up doing none of those things. That is an example of what happens when you face decision, fatigue. You end up choosing the path of least resistance because there has been so much else in your mind, on your mind, bothering you, consuming your limited cognitive space that you just end up doing the thing
或者另一个选择是我们干脆不做决定。你知道，想想你结束了一天漫长的工作回家的时候。你精疲力竭，你很累，你坐在沙发上，你必须决定是去跑步，还是去见朋友，打扫房间，或者，我不知道，出去吃晚餐。但突然之间过去了两个小时，你意识到你把整段时光都花在了沙发上刷手机上。所以你最终什么都没做。这就是当你面临决策疲劳时发生的事情的例子。你最终选择了阻力最小的道路，因为有太多其他事情充斥着你的大脑，占据了你有限的认知空间，以至于你最终只做了那件
that is easiest and that is mindlessly scrolling on your phone. Now, I will say not all indecisiveness is necessarily negative. There is definitely an important line between being decisive, being someone who gets shit done and being impulsive or being rash and not thinking things through. I think when it comes down to big decisions, it's important to have some caution. It's important to actually have a clear idea of what you want and why. And that is kind of the lucky balance that we need to strike. Not getting too caught up in the what and the why, but actually making sure that we're conscious of what we actually desire.
最简单的事情，也就是无脑刷手机。现在，我要说的是，并非所有的优柔寡断都必然是负面的。在果断、成为一个能把事情办成的人与冲动、轻率、做事不考虑后果之间，绝对有一条重要的界限。我认为在面对重大决定时，保持一些谨慎是很重要的。清楚地知道自己想要什么以及为什么想要，这确实很重要。而这正是我们需要把握的幸运平衡点。不要过分纠结于“是什么”和“为什么”，而是要确保我们对自己的真实渴望保持清醒的认识。
So there was a really interesting BBC article published a couple of years ago and it made the argument that indecisiveness actually makes us smarter because we tend to engage in more complex decision making when it comes to our choices and what we want from them. We take a lot more time to pause, to think things through. We think about things from a different perspective, right? It's kind of like you have this ball in your hand. either you pick it up and throw it or you take time to examine it. You look at it from all different angles before you end up throwing things away, before you end up just tossing it anywhere. I want to throw something else into the mix as well. So according to a recent paper from two researchers out of Germany, what matters in our life satisfaction like that research paper was
因此，几年前英国广播公司（BBC）发表了一篇非常有趣的 ലേഖ，它提出这样一个观点：优柔寡断实际上让我们变得更聪明，因为在面对选择以及我们从中想要什么时，我们倾向于参与更复杂的决策。我们花更多的时间去暂停，去把事情想清楚。我们从不同的角度思考问题，对吧？这就像你手里拿着这个球：要么你把它捡起来扔掉，要么你花时间去检验它。在你最终把东西扔掉之前，在你最终随手把它扔到哪里之前，你从不同的角度审视它。我还想引入另一个东西。因此，根据德国两位研究人员最近的一篇论文，我们的生活满意度中重要的是——正如那篇研究论文
saying before, you know, it said that if you're indecisive, you're not as happy. What they found was that it's not about being indecisive, it's actually about being ambivalent. And the two things often get confused. When we overthink what the right choice might be, what's going to make us happier, that is an indicator that you're actually thinking about your future. You actually care. You care about doing the right thing. When you're ambivalent, though, and that's why you're not making decisions, that kind of demonstrates that you just, you know, you have this level of apathy, whereby maybe there's something else going on in your life, you're unhappy, you're self-sabotaging, maybe you're even depressed,
之前所说的那样，你知道，它说如果你优柔寡断，你就不那么快乐。他们发现，关键不在于优柔寡断，而在于矛盾心理（ambivalent）。这两件事经常被混淆。当我们过度思考正确的选择可能是什么、什么会让我们更快乐时，这表明你实际上在为未来做打算。你其实在乎。你在乎做正确的事情。然而，当你充满矛盾心理时——这也是为什么你不做决定——这某种程度上表明你只是，你知道，你有这种冷漠的态度，也许你生活中有其他事情正在发生，你不快乐，你在自我毁灭，也许你甚至抑郁了，
which means that you actually don't have the energy or the motivation to care about what happens to you. And that is the worst kind of indecisiveness. Indecisiveness that comes from not caring about your future. The indecisiveness that we typically think about, though, is indecisiveness about caring too much. And I think it's super fascinating because at face value, society tends to see people who struggle making decisions as just being lazy, right? But really, they can be anxious, they can be perfectionists, they can be struggling with this concept known as choice over low depression.
这意味着你实际上没有精力或动力去关心发生在你身上的事情。而这是最糟糕的一种优柔寡断。源于不关心自己未来的优柔寡断。不过，我们通常认为的优柔寡断，是那种因为过于在乎而产生的优柔寡断。我认为这超级迷人，因为从表面上看，社会往往把那些难以做决定的人仅仅视为懒惰，对吧？但实际上，他们可能会焦虑，可能是完美主义者，可能正在与被称为“选择过多带来的抑郁”（choice over low depression）的概念作斗争。
There is so much more nuance to be had in this conversation. So what causes us to become chronically indecisive or chronic overthinkers when it comes to. to our options and our choices. Well, we're going to focus on four explanations, starting with the biggest one, which is the fear of failure or the fear of choosing wrong. A lot of us experience decision paralysis because we are very innately aware of the possibility of screwing up, right? When it comes to big life choices, even small ones, we cannot mentally handle the possibility of being wrong and then eventually regretting our decision. A lot of us fear regret, especially in our 20s,
在这场对话中，还有更多的细微差别需要探讨。那么，究竟是什么导致我们在面对选项和选择时变得长期优柔寡断或过度思考的呢？好吧，我们将重点探讨四个解释，从最大的一点开始，也就是对失败的恐惧或对选错的恐惧。我们中的许多人经历决策麻痹，是因为我们非常本能地意识到搞砸的可能性，对吧？当涉及到重大的生活选择，甚至是小的选择时，我们在心理上无法承受犯错然后最终对自己的决定感到后悔的可能性。我们中的许多人都害怕后悔，尤其是在我们二十多岁的时候，
and we know that a fear of regret contributes to inaction. When we are trying to make a choice between option A, B, C, D, what we're judging these choices by is the potential outcome. And all of this is based on hypotheticals. We don't actually know what's going to occur, right? So we are like subconsciously running this like mental pro con equation in the back of our mind to determine what we think will maximize the things that we want, whether that's happiness, wealth, pleasure, and minimize the things we don't want like pain, disappointment,
而且我们知道对后悔的恐惧会导致不作为。当我们试图在选项A、B、C、D之间做出选择时，我们通过潜在的结果来判断这些选择。所有这一切都基于假设。我们实际上并不知道会发生什么，对吧？所以我们在潜意识里在脑海后台运行这种心理利弊方程式，以决定我们认为什么能最大化我们想要的东西，无论是幸福、财富、快乐，并最小化我们不想要的东西，如痛苦、失望、
but we actually don't know how these things will turn out. And so we're faced with a lot of uncertainty. When we face uncertainty, we tend to catastrophize, which means that. that we focus excessively on how things could turn out poorly for us, rather than the likely chance that they will turn out all right. And if they don't, we'll be okay. The reason that we focus on the possibility of things going wrong is because our brains naturally want to protect us from emotionally and physically, mentally, psychologically, painful experiences. And the way that it protects us from them is by avoiding them in the first place. And the way that it avoids them in the first
但我们实际上并不知道事情会如何发展。因此，我们面临着很多不确定性。当我们面对不确定性时，我们往往会将其灾难化，这意味着我们会过度关注事情可能会对我们产生怎样糟糕的结果，而不是它们会有很大几率一切顺利。如果情况没有那么好，我们也没关系。我们之所以关注事情出错的可能性，是因为我们的大脑天生想要保护我们免受情感、身体、精神和心理上痛苦体验的伤害。而它保护我们的方式就是首先去避免这些事情。而它首先避免这些事情的方式，
place, I know, keep following me here, is by trying to predict the future. We cannot predict the future. So instead, we choose the option that makes us feel safe and more comfortable. And what ends up happening is that we get so worked up by what could possibly occur that we just don't make any decision at all. not making a decision makes us feel less responsible if the worst case scenario were to happen. It's also why we kind of constantly seek reassurance from others, right? We ask our friends what they think we should do. We get our parents or even our partner to make our choices for us, whether that's like deciding on the restaurant for tonight or the plans or the movie.
我知道，继续听我说，就是试图预测未来。我们无法预测未来。所以相反，我们会选择那个让我们感到安全和舒适的选项。最终发生的情况是，我们被可能发生的事情折腾得心力交瘁，以至于根本不做任何决定。如果不做决定的话，在发生最坏情况时，我们会觉得自己承担的责任更少。这也是为什么我们总是不断寻求他人的保证，对吧？我们问朋友觉得我们该怎么做。我们让父母甚至伴侣帮我们做选择，不管是决定今晚去哪家餐厅、做什么计划还是看什么电影。
All of this is a way of reducing or even eliminating our sense of personal responsibility, and accountability that we believe might contribute to a greater sense of disappointment or regret if things aren't as good as we thought they would be. If the restaurant is a letdown, if we actually end up screwing up our lives, at least we can kind of maintain a sense of like, well, at least it wasn't my fault. At least it wasn't all me. At least these people helped me. In this day and age, we are also increasingly facing a bias known as choice overload.
所有这一切都是为了减少甚至消除我们的个人责任感，如果我们认为事情没有想象中那么好，这种责任感可能会加剧我们的失望或遗憾感。如果餐厅令人失望，如果我们最终把生活搞砸了，至少我们可以保持一种心态，即“好吧，至少这不是我的错。至少不全是我的错。至少这些人帮了我”。在这个时代，我们还日益面临着一种被称为“选择过载”的偏见。
So it is both a blessing and a curse that this generation, we have so much freedom to choose what we want with our lives. More than any generation before us, we have so much freedom to decide whether we want to work full time, whether we want to go back to uni, pick up a trade or travel or freelance or pursue our creative interests or work behind a bar. I think especially with the creation invention of the internet, our eyes are a lot more open. to the opportunity that this world provides. But researchers have begun to notice that when we have too many options, this actually has the opposite effect that we would assume. It doesn't necessarily make us feel more free.
因此，我们这一代人拥有如此多的自由来选择我们想要的生活，这既是一种祝福，也是一种诅咒。比我们之前的任何一代人都多，我们有如此多的自由来决定我们是想全职工作、重返大学、学习一门手艺、旅行、自由职业、追求创作兴趣还是在酒吧打工。我认为，特别是随着互联网的创造和发明，我们的世界变得更加开阔，看到了这个世界所提供的机遇。但研究人员开始注意到，当我们有太多选择时，这实际上会产生与我们预期的相反的效果。它并不一定会让我们感到更加自由。
It actually makes us feel in a really strange, counterintuitive way. It makes us feel more restricted. Because now, now that we have more options, we start to perceive that we have a greater risk of, of choosing the wrong one, if that makes sense. So if you only had two job offers to consider versus, let's say, six, there is like a 50-50 chance that you'll choose the right job in the first scenario. And in the second scenario where there are like six different options,
用一种非常奇怪、违反直觉的方式，它实际上让我们感到更加受限。因为现在，既然我们有了更多的选择，我们就会开始觉得选择错误选项的风险更高了，如果可以这样理解的话。所以，如果你只有两个工作机会要考虑，假设对比六个，在第一种情况下，你选对工作的几率大概是五十对五十。而在第二种情况下，有大约六个不同的选项，
there's only a 15% chance that you're going to choose the best case scenario. Obviously, there are other factors that come into consideration and things aren't always coming down to that kind of simplistic math. But that's how our brain sees it. Our brain sees all these things in front of us and goes, okay, more opportunities, that is more information to consider. There is more of a risk that we're going to choose the wrong one, essentially. We also tend to feel like with each choice, we kind of close more doors than we open, which is really scary, especially when we are so young and we want to feel really free and liberated and able to do what we want. So again, we put off making a decision to keep our options open when in fact what we're actually doing is closing ourselves off because we're never fully embracing those opportunities.
你选到最好情况的几率只有15%。显然后面还有其他因素需要考虑，事情并不总是归结为那种过于简单的数学计算。但我们的大脑就是这么看的。我们的大脑看到眼前的所有这些事情，然后心想：好吧，更多的机遇意味着需要考虑更多的信息。本质上讲，我们选错的风险更大了。我们往往还觉得，每一次选择都会让我们关闭更多的门，而不是打开更多的门，这真的很吓人，尤其是当我们还这么年轻，想要感到真正的自由和解放，能够去做自己想做的事时。所以再次地，我们推迟做决定以保持选项开放，而实际上我们正在做的是把自己封闭起来，因为我们从未完全拥抱那些机遇。
We're just keeping them there in case we might decide one day that we want to do them. So it's really interesting because when we are indecisive and we are forced to make a decision, we actually tend to look at less information than people who are more decisive. Because we understand intuitively that more information is going to make it a lot more difficult for us to choose just one thing. We don't want to get caught up in this choice overload. One researcher put it really well. So, for instance, you're an indecisive person and you're shopping for a car.
我们只是把它们留在那里，以防有一天我们决定想要去尝试。所以这真的很有趣，因为当我们优柔寡断并被迫做出决定时，我们实际上往往比那些更果断的人查看更少的信息。因为我们凭直觉理解，更多的信息只会让我们更难只选择一件事。我们不想陷入这种选择过载中。一位研究人员对此做了很好的阐释。例如，你是一个优柔寡断的人，正在选购一辆汽车。
And what you might do is willfully choose to not do as much research as you should so that you have fewer options, so that you have fewer things to consider. That is like one way of being strategic about our indecisiveness so that we don't overload ourselves. But the thing is, is that in those situations, we don't make an informed decision, right? We just made an easier decision. We recognize that if we were to have all the information, to have all the facts, there is no way that we're getting through all that. There is no way that we are not going to, that we are going to make a choice and not have some kind of doubts about it, because that's where like our decisional procrastination comes in. It might not surprise you either that people with ADHD
你可能会做的事情是，刻意选择不做应有的那么多研究，这样你就有了更少的选项，从而需要考虑的事情更少。这是针对我们的优柔寡断采取策略的一种方式，这样我们就不会让自己不堪重负。但问题是，在那种情况下，我们并没有做出明智的决定，对吧？我们只是做了一个更容易的决定。我们意识到，如果我们掌握了所有的信息、所有的事实，我们绝对无法处理完所有这些。我们绝对无法做到在做出选择的同时不对其产生某种怀疑，因为这就是我们的决策拖延症发挥作用的时候。患有ADHD的人也更容易出现这种情况，你可能不会感到惊讶，
are more prone to this as well because they already feel overwhelmed by a lot of information coming from their environment. So making choices like this becomes agony. I think across all neurotypes, indecisiveness is also more pronounced. If you are someone who just lacks a certain level of confidence in your own skills and abilities, in your ability to make good choices. Now, our confidence really derives from our sense of self-esteem. how resilient, competent, intelligent we see ourselves as being, and therefore to what degree
因为他们已经对来自环境的大量信息感到不堪重负。所以做这样的选择成了一种痛苦。我认为在所有神经类型中，优柔寡断也更加明显。如果你是一个对自己的技能和能力、对自己做出明智选择的能力缺乏一定自信的人。现在，我们的自信实际上源于我们的自尊感。即我们认为自己有多强的韧性、能力、聪明程度，因此我们在多大程度上
we feel that we can trust our assessments of a decision or a choice. Our level of confidence in our decision-making ability comes back to how we were raised, as most things in psychology tend to do. There's always some kind of behavioral, psychological, mental origin in childhood. So if you were raised in a family in which you had maybe overbearing, parents, that's one example, especially an authoritarian father. That's what one study suggests that it's not just about an overbearing mother, but an overbearing father in particular. If you were raised in that environment and you never had the opportunity to make decisions, or you were raised
觉得我们可以信任自己对某个决定或选择的评估。我们对决策能力的自信程度可以追溯到我们的成长经历，心理学中的大多数事情往往都是如此。童年中总会有某种行为、心理、精神上的根源。所以如果你在一个家庭中长大，你的父母可能有些专制，这是一个例子，尤其是专制父亲。一项研究表明，这不仅仅关乎专制的母亲，尤其是专制的父亲。如果你是在那种环境下长大的，从没有机会做决定，或者你是在
in an environment where any small failure was really intensely criticized, you don't feel strong enough in your ability to trust yourself and the choices that you're making. So in those situations when your hand is kind of forced, you genuinely are paralyzed. You have this constant mental back and forth, not because you don't know what you want, but because you don't trust what you want. You don't trust that this might not lead to some kind of consequence that you can't foresee. You're not used to making decisions for yourself. You feel like if you are to mess up, you're going to be criticized. People are going to judge you. So you spend more time thinking things through. So family is another explanation. But another component of our indecisiveness that I find
任何微小的失败都会受到强烈批评的环境中长大的，你在信任自己以及自己所做选择的能力上就会感到不够坚定。所以在这种情况下，当你有点被迫做出选择时，你会真正陷入瘫痪。你内心会不断地权衡拉扯，不是因为你不知道自己想要什么，而是因为你不相信自己想要的东西。你不相信这会不会导致某种你无法预见的后果。你不习惯为自己做决定。你觉得如果搞砸了，你就会受到批评。大家会对你评头论足。所以你花更多的时间深思熟虑。所以家庭是另一个解释。但我发现我们的优柔寡断中另一个
particularly interesting, I think this relates to me a lot, is the interactions between indecisiveness, perfectionism, and anxiety. Now, perfectionism is a very broad personality trait. It essentially describes people who are overly concerned with striving for flawlessness. And they're very critical of themselves when they don't meet the kind of unrealistic standards. or goals that they set for themselves. When they fail to meet their own expectations, or maybe those of others, but normally they are self-imposed expectations,
特别有趣的组成部分，我认为这与我自身有很大关系，那就是优柔寡断、完美主义和焦虑之间的相互作用。现在，完美主义是一个非常广泛的人格特质。它本质上描述的是那些过度关注追求完美无瑕的人。当他们没有达到自己为自己设定的那种不切实际的标准或目标时，他们对自己非常苛刻。当他们未能达到自己的期望，或者可能是别人的期望，但通常是他们自己强加的期望时，
this just means they place a lot more pressure on themselves to do better next time, to not make that mistake again, to make sure that we are hitting our targets every time, we're making the perfect decisions, we cannot screw up. And so it makes them incredibly hypervigilant to the possibility of mistakes.
这仅仅意味着他们给自己施加了更大的压力，要求下次做得更好，不要再犯那个错误，确保我们每次都能达成目标，做出完美的决定，我们绝对不能搞砸。因此，这让他们对可能出现错误的情况变得极其高度警惕。
perfectionism makes it so hard to make decisions because like we said before you just don't know what's going to happen sometimes and it's this trait that is a lot higher in people who display anxious traits or who have anxiety anxiety really exacerbates our perfectionism because there is this innate tendency within both to really overthink or ruminate on what could go wrong and what has gone wrong in the past. So that makes it really hard to not be focused on what could go wrong in the future. So as a result, our perfectionism means that it takes a lot of time to work through small choices, small decisions, because they take on a whole new degree of importance.
完美主义让做决定变得无比艰难，因为就像我们之前说的，有时你根本不知道会发生什么，而且这种特质在表现出焦虑特质或患有焦虑症的人身上要高得多。焦虑确实会加剧我们的完美主义，因为这两者内部都有一种天生的倾向，会过度思考或反刍可能出错的事情以及过去出错的事情。所以这让人很难不把注意力放在未来可能会出错的事情上。因此，结果就是，我们的完美主义意味着我们需要花费大量时间来处理细小的选择和小决定，因为它们被赋予了全新的重要性。
If everything has to be perfect, if everything has to go according to plan and be flawless, then we're not taking any chances here. We're taking all the time we can get to make sure that we know exactly what we're doing and that this is the right thing for us. Because again, we can't cope with the idea of misstepping. So we delay any kind of action or movement towards our goals. We become, again, just so paralyzed in the contemplation stage. We think that if we stay there long enough, eventually we're going to be able to see some kind of have some epiphany about what we should be. do, that the future will reveal itself to us, we'll know exactly what the perfect plan is,
如果一切都必须完美，如果一切都必须按计划进行且完美无瑕，那么我们就不会在这里碰运气。我们会利用所有能利用的时间，确保我们确切知道自己在做什么，并且这对我们来说是正确的选择。因为同样地，我们无法接受迈错步子的想法。因此，我们延迟了采取任何行动或朝着目标前进的步伐。我们再次陷入沉思阶段而无法动弹。我们以为只要在那里待得够久，最终我们就能对我们应该成为什么样的人有所顿悟，
what exactly what's going to like optimize everything in our lives. If we go to this school, then we're going to get this job and we're going to live in this city and make this much money and meet this person. That is never going to be clear. A lot of decision making kind of comes down to chance. A lot of the outcomes of our decision comes down to chance. and chance is not something we can control, which means that it's not something that really lends itself to creating like the perfect life, to making ourselves feel flawless and perfect, to allowing
未来会向我们展露自己，我们会确切知道完美的计划是什么，到底是什么能优化我们生活中的一切。如果我们上了这所学校，然后我们就会得到这份工作，然后我们就会在这个城市生活，赚这么多钱，遇到这个人。这一切永远不会清晰。很多决策在很大程度上取决于运气。我们决定的很多结果都取决于运气，而运气不是我们能控制的东西，这意味着它并不适合用来创造完美的生活，让我们觉得自己无懈可击、十全十美，从而允许
ourselves to meet our high standards. Not to kind of be a dead horse, but I think perfectionism is also a real breeding ground for unrealistic expectations, right? As annoying as it is, you can't get it right. movie you choose to watch isn't going to be your favorite. Every restaurant isn't going to be amazing. Sometimes you do wish that you could go back. But sadly, you can't. And you have to make the most of what you have. That's especially hard for perfectionists because perfectionism. Of course, it doesn't leave any room for that kind of self-compassion. It doesn't leave any room for valuing what we learn, for valuing our mistakes. Because that is not on the agenda, right? That does not match the overall mission of getting everything right the first time.
自己达到高标准。并不是老调重弹，但我认为完美主义确实是不切实际期望的温床，对吧？不管多么令人讨厌，你不可能每件事都做对。你选择观看的电影不一定会是你最喜欢的。每家餐厅不可能都好得惊人。有时你确实希望能够回到过去。但遗憾的是，你不能。你必须充分利用你所拥有的。对于完美主义者来说，这一点尤其困难，因为完美主义当然不给那种自我同情留任何空间。它不留任何空间去珍视我们学到了什么，珍视我们的犯错。因为这不在议程上，对吧？这与一开始就把每件事都做对的总体使命不符。
So we've kind of got a good lay of the land around what causes our chronic indecisiveness. And that's all great. You know, that's all fine and lovely. But knowing that, what do we do about it? If we're just sick of getting stuck in the analysis paralysis, of wasting our time, of feeling judged because we get stuck and we're stuck overthinking, we can't truly confront our fears. We need to make the perfect choice. What do we do about it? What do we do about it so that we can accept failure as being part of this process, except that it's not going to be
所以我们基本上大致了解了导致我们长期优柔寡断的原因。这都很好。你知道，这都挺好也挺可爱的。但知道了这些之后，我们该怎么办？如果我们已经厌倦了陷入分析性瘫痪、浪费时间、因为陷入困境和过度思考而感到被人评判，我们无法真正面对恐惧。我们需要做出完美的决定。我们该怎么办？我们该如何应对，从而能够接受失败是这个过程的一部分，接受它不可能
the correct decision every time, but still move forward and still actually do something. Well, I'm going to talk about all of that and more after this short break, so stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
每一次都是正确的决定，但仍然继续前进并真正付诸行动？好吧，在短暂的休息之后，我将讨论所有这些以及更多内容，请继续收听。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中。我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养精神坚韧度、体能和抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看透那些主导健康行业的古怪且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world, are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%.
我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力造成的。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即数字TWO%。
On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush to do a little kill.
在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA上拍打小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和小金有什么关系。
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack.
好吧，你可以在《Look Back At It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个时刻，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。其中包括最近一集请来了马克·拉蒙特·希尔，大谈80年代的快克可卡因。坦白说，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我很乐意在某天聊聊快克，只是为了让你们都知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。
So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿线。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在了台面上。谢谢你把话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade. of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase
在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖姆斯。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了十多年的心理健康领域个人经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程了
that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth.
我们没有意识到自己已经拥有了那个东西。我们还在追逐它。我们也不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在记分牌上计较。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross）。因为你觉得在世上做一个好人很重要。
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway.
你做一个好人是因为害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。完全正确。这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。加入我，我是基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines），在我的新播客《硬核领悟》（Learn the Hardway）中，我们将就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。
Open your free, Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct?
打开免费的 iHeart Radio 应用。搜索《硬核领悟》（Learn the Hardway）并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她言辞中明显的自相矛盾。这开启了长达数年的法庭之战以证明真相。你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试，斯内尔斯女士，对吧？
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian and Michael Maranchini. My mind was blown.
我篡改过一次测试。这动用了大批网络侦探才破了案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们发现了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安（Greg Alesspian）和迈克尔·马拉奇尼（Michael Maranchini）。我震惊了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. curing or overcoming our indecisiveness is not as simple as most people would think. It's not about giving
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱情陷阱》（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这还没结束。在 iHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方收听《爱情陷阱》（Love Trapped）播客。治愈或克服我们的优柔寡断并不像大多数人想象的那么简单。这不关乎给予
ourselves time limits. It's not about going over the options and making pro-conless. It's not about choosing randomly. And it's not about just swallowing your fear and hoping that it goes away. That might work for some people and congratulations if it does. You have done my work for me. but I think that when we use those band-aid fixes of being impulsive or just trying to like force ourselves into something that feels unnatural, we're inevitably going to revert back to our previous pattern and habit of procrastination and contemplation. So what we actually are required to do is identify why it is that you feel stuck, why it is that you lack confidence, why it is that you feel failure,
我们自己时间限制。这不关乎梳理选项并列出优缺点清单。这不关乎随机选择。这也不关乎咬牙忍住恐惧、祈祷它自行消失。这对某些人可能管用，如果管用了，恭喜你。你替我把活儿干了。但我认为，当我们使用那些冲动行事的创可贴式解决方法，或者只是试图强迫自己去做一些感觉不自然的事情时，我们不可避免地会回到之前拖延和反复思索的模式与习惯中。所以我们实际需要做的是，找出你为什么会感到困惑，为什么缺乏自信，为什么会感受到失败，
that you are perfectionist, that you are anxious or ambivalent, and start from there. Address the root cause before you can kind of address the problem, right? So the biggest contributor, as we discussed, is fear of failure and perfectionism. We can't cope with the possibility of things not turning out how we'd like or experiencing regret. In order to overcome this, we need to focus on being good, not perfect. and we call this the 80-20 rule. So the 80-20 rule is actually something that I learned from my previous workplace. Shout out to them when I was a consultant back in the day.
你是一个完美主义者，你感到焦虑或矛盾，然后从这里开始。在解决问题之前先找到根本原因，对吧？所以正如我们所讨论的，最大的诱因是对失败的恐惧和完美主义。我们无法承受事情不如预期发展或经历遗憾的可能性。为了克服这一点，我们需要专注于做到优秀，而不是完美。我们将这称为80-20法则。所以80-20法则其实是我从之前的工作中学到的东西。向他们致敬，当年我还是个顾问的时候。
And essentially the premise is that in anything that you do, it doesn't need to be 100% amazing. It only needs to be 80% amazing. And you have 20% like room for error, 20% like space to not be perfect. This stops us from obsessing over the minor, small details, and we focus on the things that are going to be most important. And we focus on just getting that 80% right so that we don't get stuck on the final 20% and end up kind of losing all the work that we've done before that. Right. Like if, for example, you have an essay that you're trying to get done and you're getting incredibly indecisive about like, what topic am I going to choose?
其核心前提是，在你做的任何事情中，它都不需要达到100%的完美。它只需要达到80%的完美。你拥有20%的犯错空间，20%不需要完美的空间。这阻止了我们去纠结那些微不足道的细节，让我们专注于最重要的事情。我们专注于把那80%做好，这样我们就不会纠结于最后20%，从而最终弄丢了之前所做的一切工作。对吧。比如，如果你有一篇论文要写，而你对“我该选择什么主题”变得极其优柔寡断，
What am I going to write it on? is this right? Is this good research? Is this going to get me an A? You're spending so much time focusing on everything being correct that you're actually sacrificing 100% of the project, right? But if you said, okay, I'm just going to start and I'm just going to focus on getting it about like 80% there, 80% happy with it, you realize that that remaining 20% isn't actually that big of a deal. And so it stops your brain. from getting stuck in the loop. It takes the pressure off. You know, your new 100 is 80.
“我该写什么内容？”“这正确吗？”“这是好的研究吗？”“这能让我拿A吗？”你花了大量时间关注每件事都正确，以至于你实际上牺牲了整个项目的100%，对吧？但如果你说，好吧，我只是要开始写，我只专注于把它完成大约80%，对它有80%的满意度，你就会意识到剩下的20%其实没那么大不了。因此它阻止了你的大脑陷入死循环。这减轻了压力。你知道，你新的100分就是80分。
And that 20% is a nice buffer. I also saw some amazing advice that said, getting 10 things done at 85% or 80%, so good but not perfect, is going to do a lot more for your life than getting five things done 100% perfectly and stressing out over the other five things that you didn't do. I think in that situation, right, it really goes to show that We spend a lot more time actually worrying about the stuff that we didn't do than the stuff that we did do. And when we think about that in the context of our decisions,
而那20%是一个很好的缓冲。我还看到过一个极好的建议，那就是把10件事做到85%或80%的完成度——虽然很好但并不完美——这对你人生的帮助，要远大于把5件事做到100%的完美，却为另外5件没做好的事感到压力山大。我认为在这种情况下，对吧，这真的表明，我们花在担心那些没做的事情上的时间，其实远远多于我们真正去做的事情。当我们把这一点放在我们做决定的背景下来看时，
we spend a lot more time worrying about regret than actually experiencing regret. I think it's also important to delineate between the big decisions and the small ones and focus on what is important. Devote your time to that rather than getting held up and all the small stuff and getting stuck in a rut of decision fatigue, think about the decisions you need to make as if they are on a scale. You have your littles, you have your mediums, you have your massives. The littles are the daily choices that won't really impact you for more than like maximum 24 hours. You can make most of them pretty impulsively or quickly and most of the time they won't matter.
我们花在担心遗憾上的时间，远多于真正经历遗憾的时间。我认为，区分重大决定和微小决定并专注于重要的事情也很重要。把你的时间投入到那些事情上去，而不是纠缠于所有琐事，陷入决策疲劳的泥潭。把你需要做的事情想象成在一个天平上。你有微小的决定，有中等的决定，有重大的决定。微小的决定是那些对你的影响不会超过最多24小时的日常选择。你可以非常冲动或迅速地做出大部分决定，而且大多数时候它们都无关紧要。
What you choose to eat, what you choose to wear, what you do in the evening, you can over. overthink them if you'd like and you can catastrophize each little one. But A, you just create more stress for yourself and you don't deserve that. And B, you probably won't even end up enjoying whatever it is that you choose because you're constantly comparing it to something potentially better. So by focusing on the bigger stuff, we free up a lot of cognitive space that is probably better devoted to the things that are actually going to matter. It's also important to remember that every outcome normally turns out to be okay. Because usually we end up happy with what we have and we do our best with our circumstances
你选择吃什么，你选择穿什么，你晚上做什么，如果你愿意的话，你可以过度思考它们，你可以把每一个小决定都灾难化。但第一，你只是给自己制造了更多压力，你罪不至此；第二，你可能最后根本不会享受你所选择的东西，因为你总是把它和潜在更好的东西作比较。因此，通过专注于更大的事情，我们释放了大量的认知空间，这些空间其实更适合投入到那些真正重要的事情上去。同样重要的是要记住，每一个结果通常都会转危为安。因为通常我们最终会对我们拥有的感到满意，并且我们会尽最大努力利用我们的环境，
regardless of what got us there. It's not, if you're caring this much about these small decisions, that is great because that's not going to be harsh about it, but that's not going to disappear. You're not ambivalent. You're not apathetic. You do care. And that level of care is going to carry with you regardless of whether the decisions you're making now turn out great, amazing, fabulous or not so great. There's no way of knowing if it
无论是什么让我们走到了这一步。不是这样的，如果你对这些小决定的关心程度如此之高，那很好，因为这不会很苛刻，但这不会消失。你并不是矛盾。你也不是冷漠。你确实在乎。无论你现在做出的决定最终是绝佳、惊艳、美妙，还是不那么理想，这种程度的关心都会伴随着你。你无法预知它
would have turned out differently. You just have to focus on the moment you're in and how you can make your current circumstances better right now. You have all of the necessary skills to get yourself out of a situation you don't want to be in. And if you made the wrong choice, your decisions aren't permanent. They can be undone. The only decisions you can't undo are the ones that you didn't make. are the ones that you spent being indecisive about to the point where life just kind of made the decision for you. You know, you can change courses at uni. You can switch jobs. You can move back to your old hometown. You can return early from a trip, whatever it is. But at 80, 90, 100 years old, you can't come back to where you are right now and make these choices. You can't come back
是否会有所不同。你只需要专注于你所处的当下，以及你现在如何能让目前的处境变得更好。你拥有所有必要的技能，能够让自己脱离一个你不想待的境地。如果你做错了选择，你的决定也不是永久性的。它们是可以撤销的。你唯一无法撤销的决定，就是你没有做出的决定。就是那些你一直优柔寡断，直到生活替你做出了决定的那些时刻。你知道的，你可以在大学里转专业。你可以换工作。你可以搬回老家。你可以提前结束旅行，无论是什么。但在80、90、100岁的时候，你无法回到现在的起点重新做出这些选择。你无法回来
and tell yourself, just do it. It's not going to matter. Just do the damn thing. You can't reverse the regrets that you have around your inaction. So it makes more sense to just do the thing, even if you're not sure. And I also think it's important to shift your mindset from seeing mistakes as a failure to being part of the plan. Mistakes are a necessary ingredient. They're part of the process. We learn more from the times things didn't go our way than the times they did,
告诉自己：做吧。这没什么大不了的。就把这破事儿做了吧。你无法逆转你因不作为而感到的遗憾。所以，哪怕你不确定，直接去做了也更有意义。而且我认为同样重要的是，要转变心态，不要把犯错视为失败，而是将其视为计划的一部分。错误是必不可少的成分。它们是过程的一部分。与事情顺风顺水的时候相比，我们从事情不如意的时候学到的东西更多，
because these situations provide a space for reflection and redirection. If everything goes perfectly, according to plan, 100% tick, tick, tick, we never fail. We also never grow because growth comes from discomfort. It comes from learning, pushing past fear and realizing that even if things don't turn out completely okay, you're going to be totally fine. You're going to be okay. Something else that really works for me is to actually let my fear get as big as it wants. I let myself catastrophes, even if it seems a little bit counterintuitive, hear me out.
因为这些情况为反思和调整提供了空间。如果一切都完美进行，百分之百按计划打勾，我们从未失败。我们也从未成长，因为成长来自于不适。它来自于学习、突破恐惧，并意识到即使事情没有完全朝着好的方向发展，你也绝对会没事的。你会好起来的。另一个对我真正管用的方法是，实际上让我的恐惧无限放大。我让自己去灾难化，即使这听起来有点反直觉，听我解释。
The reason I do this is because when you stare at the worst case scenario, when you look at it head on, when you make it as big and scary as you possibly can, it's never actually that bad. There is always a way out. You realize that actually the thing that you're overthinking, in the grand scheme of things, it's not life-ending. It's really not that important. It's not going to destroy you. It's all coming down to the fact that our brain likes to focus on what is scary and what it thinks is dangerous to protect us, even if that thing is not as important in reality. Okay, I have two final tips for you. The first one is to choose your advice selectively. I think sometimes we use excessive advice seeking as a way to put off making a decision.
我这么做的原因是因为，当你直视最坏的情况，当你正面迎难而上，当你把它放大到你所能想象的最恐怖的程度时，它其实从来没有那么糟。总有一条出路。你会意识到，实际上你一直在过度思考的那件事，从宏观角度来看，并不是世界末日。它真的没那么重要。它不会毁了你。这一切归根结底是因为，为了保护我们，我们的大脑喜欢关注那些可怕的、它认为是危险的事物，哪怕那件事在现实中并没有那么重要。好吧，我最后给你两个建议。第一个是精挑细选你的建议。我认为有时我们通过过度寻求建议来作为推迟做决定的借口。
When we do this, we get stuck in the information gathering stage where we mistakenly believe that the more we know, the better and easier the decision will be. That is unfortunately incorrect, as we know already, because it creates choice overload, information overload. It means that there is just too many factors, too many things to add to the procon list. So choose your trusted people, and I would say choose two of them, whether that is a parent and your best friend, a partner. a mentor, and then of course you have yourself. There's three people there who get to have a say in what you're going to decide. Then make a decision based on averages. If, you know, your best friend and your boyfriend both think that you should do the thing, you should obviously do it. You don't need to seek any further advice. And if you feel the need to, I think that's really revealing. It's so fascinating
当我们这样做时，我们就会陷入信息收集阶段，误以为我们知道得越多，决定就会越好、越容易。正如我们已经知道的那样，这不幸地是错误的，因为它会造成选择过载、信息过载。这意味着有太多的因素，有太多要加入优缺点清单的东西。所以选择你信任的人，我建议选择两个，无论是父母、你的最好朋友、伴侣、导师，然后当然还有你自己。那里有三个人可以对你将要决定的事情发表意见。然后根据平均值做出决定。如果，你知道的，你最好的朋友和你的男友都认为你应该去做那件事，你显然应该去做。你不需要寻求任何进一步的建议。如果你觉得有必要，我认为这真的很能说明问题。这太奇妙了
because when other people tell us what we should do, it often makes us more aware of what we really want. it's like when you're trying to decide what you want for dinner, right? And you ask your friend, do you want Thai food or do you want pizza? I can't really choose. You sell them like, I just, I don't care. You choose. It's all up to you. And then they say pizza and you're like, damn it, I really want a Thai food.
因为当别人告诉我们该做什么时，它往往能让我们更清楚地知道自己真正想要什么。这就好像当你试图决定晚餐想吃什么时，对吧？你问你的朋友，你想吃泰国菜还是披萨？我真的选不出来。你对他们说，我不在乎。你来选。全听你的。然后他们说披萨，而你会想：该死，我其实超想吃泰国菜的。
And that is how you reveal your preference. The same goes for some of our bigger choices, right? When someone else has a strong opinion about what you should do, sometimes it causes an equally strong reaction in us that reveals our preferences done, there you go. You know what you need to do now. And finally, this is not like a practical thing, but go easy on yourself. I just want to remind you, you are one small person and in the grand scheme of things, it might feel comforting, maybe it doesn't, but you know what, your choices are not going to end the world. They're not going to destroy lives. Most of the time, anything that you do
这就是你如何揭示自己的偏好。我们的一些重大抉择也是如此，对吧？当别人对你该做什么有强烈的意见时，有时会在我们心中引起同样强烈的反应，从而暴露出我们的偏好——干得好，就是这样。你现在知道自己该做什么了。最后，这其实不是什么实用技巧，但放轻松点。我只是想提醒你，你只是个渺小的人，从宏观角度来看，这可能会让你感到安慰，也可能不会，但你知道吗，你的选择不会毁灭世界。它们不会毁了生活。大多数时候，你所做的任何事
can be reversed. Anything that you do, you can fix. you can add on to, it's not the end. Don't feel like you are locked into any one decision. Don't let your decisions take on more gravity and severity than they deserve. If it's not going to matter in five years, do not spend more than five seconds thinking about it. In fact, sometimes the decisions that we're not too sure of actually bring about even better scenarios than we ever could have imagined in the first place because we can't predict
都是可以逆转的。你做的任何事，你都可以修复。你可以进行补救，这并不是终点。不要觉得自己被锁死在任何一个决定中。不要让你的决定承担超过它们应有的严重性和分量。如果五年后这事根本不重要，那就不要花超过五秒钟去想它。事实上，有时那些我们不太确定的决定，反而会带来比我们最初想象的还要美好的场景，因为我们无法预测
the future. And if we tried, we normally end up with the future that we didn't even think of in the first place. So take the pressure off. It's all going to be okay. I saw someone say this the other day, but there is no one best choice. There is no one decision that is going to completely change your life. You can make the best of the outcome. You can make the best of what happens.
未来。如果我们试图去预测，我们通常会迎来一个我们最初压根没想到的未来。所以放轻松。一切都会好起来的。我前几天看到有人这么说，但世上没有哪个选择是绝对最好的。没有哪个决定会彻底改变你的人生。你可以让结果达到最好。你可以让发生的事情变得最好。
It's actually not about the decision. It's about the conscious daily choices that you make. to just keep going with your life, to keep yourself well, to keep yourself focused, to keep yourself on a path. You know, it doesn't really come down to the big decisions. It comes down to the small, daily choices, the littles, like I said before, that you can make quite quickly. So you've got this, believe in your capacity to make good choices. Remember that if you don't, it's not the end of the world, you have a chance to do it over. You have a chance to reverse decisions, change your mind and do them.
这其实不关乎那个决定。这关乎你每天有意识做出的那些选择。为了让生活继续，为了保持健康，为了保持专注，为了让自己留在一条道路上。你知道的，这其实不取决于重大的决定。这取决于日常的小选择，就像我之前说的那些微小的、你可以相当快做出的小选择。所以你能行的，相信自己有能力做出好的选择。记住，如果你没做到，那也不是世界末日，你还有机会重来。你还有机会逆转决定、改变主意并付诸行动。
So go gentle on yourself. I really hope that you enjoyed this episode. I hope you learnt something. I hope that it was comforting. And if there was someone else in your life who needs to hear this, please feel free to share it with them. And leave a five-star review on Apple Podcast, Spotify, wherever you're listening right now. Make sure you're following along for future episodes.
所以对你自己温柔一点。我真的希望你喜欢这一集。希望你学到了一些东西。希望它能给你带来安慰。如果你的生活中还有其他人需要听到这些，请随时分享给他们。并在苹果播客、Spotify或你现在收听的任何地方留下五星好评。确保关注我们以收听未来的节目。
If you enjoyed this episode, please let me know. know, I would love to hear from you. I actually feel really indecisive when I make this show sometimes. I really worry about the episodes I put out and like if anybody's going to relate to them, if anybody even cares. Like, I always think, oh, what if people see this episode and they're like, well, I'm not going to listen to that because it doesn't apply to me. And then they never listen again.
如果你喜欢这一集，请让我知道，我很希望能听到你的反馈。其实有时我在制作这个节目时也会感到非常优柔寡断。我真的很担心自己发布的节目，比如是否会有人产生共鸣，是否会有人甚至在乎。比如，我总是想，天哪，如果人们看到这一集然后觉得，嗯，我才不听这个，因为它对我不适用，那怎么办？然后他们就再也不听了。
That is an example of how I catastrophize my small, tiny choices. So like I said, I'm in the same boat. I would love to hear from you if you enjoyed this episode, if you can put my own sense of self-doubt to rest. And until next week, be kind. Be gentle to yourself. And we will see you soon. Hey, what's good, y'all?
这就是我如何将微小的小选择灾难化的一个例子。所以就像我说的，我们同病相怜。如果你喜欢这一集，我很希望能听到你的反馈，好让我自己的自我怀疑之心得以安息。直到下周，保持善良。对你自己温柔一点。我们很快再见。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to.
欢迎收听《硬核领悟》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方进行都不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位懂行的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？它向世界释放出的信号是：你可别想招惹我。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Snellins, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian,
在 iHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方收听《硬核领悟》（Learn the Hardway）。2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控令人生下双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试，斯内尔斯女士，对吧？我篡改过一次测试。这动用了大批网络侦探才揭露了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安（Greg Alesspian），
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%.
迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱情陷阱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在 iHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方收听《爱情陷阱》（Love Trapped）播客。2%。
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts,
这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》（2%）中，我将剖析精神坚韧、健身的科学，以及在我们这个奇异的现代世界中建立抗压能力的方法。经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》（2%）。也就是在 iHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客上搜索 TWA%
or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, They take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends.
或者在任何你收听播客的地方。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。
Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
相信我，宝贝。在 iHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方收听。这是一档 iHeart 播客。保证由人类创作。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。